ein sommer ohne spiele bei olympia in
tokio findet wegen corona erst kommendes
jahr statt eine historisch einmalige
entscheidung masken marke eigenbau weil
es an atemschutz mangelt stellen immer
mehr unternehmen ihre produktion um und
trauer um alberta so der asterix
erfinder und zeichner ist tot seine
comic helden bleiben unsterblich
[Musik]
die nachrichten nicht da das wollte mit
christian sievers guten abend in allen
auch heute wieder wir haben in den
kommenden zwanzig minuten den
nachrichtenüberblick für sie und der
beginnt mit einer nachricht die es in
friedenszeiten so noch nie gegeben hat
die olympischen spiele werden verschoben
sie sollen weiterhin tokio 2020 heißen
aber erst 2021 statt finden
das internationale olympische komitee
war unter erheblichen druck geraten zu
reagieren auf die weltweite corona
epidemie verschiedene sportler und
verbände hatten ihre teilnahme bereits
abgesagt denn das virus hatte in den
vergangenen wochen schon fast den
gesamten profisport weltweit außer
gefecht gesetzt beispiel fußball hier
geht nichts mehr die europameisterschaft
verschoben oder die formel 1 1 rennen
nach dem anderen gestrichen
und jetzt also auch das mega-ereignis
olympia peter leissl mit den details
high noon 12 uhr mittags am sitz des
internationalen olympischen kommitees
ein kurzes telefonat aus lausanne ins
abendliche olympisch geschmückte tokio
die zwei entscheider waren sich schnell
einig japans premier boc chef thomas
bach hat meinen vorschlag zu 100 prozent
akzeptiert wir werden die olympischen
spiele und paralympics im sommer 20 21
austragen
sein gegenüber sieht den hauptgrund in
den gestiegenen corona fallzahlen
weltweit die sorge um die weltgesundheit
das war der druck der da da war diese
sich schnell entwickelnden zahlen
die haben uns bewogen es geht hier um
menschenleben und
dahin dahinter haben olympische spiele
dann zurückzustehen noch vorgestern
hatte sich bach vier wochen bedenkzeit
erbeten das war nicht zu halten es gab
eine lawine von kritiken erste absagen
ganzer länder wie die von kanada eine
überfällige entscheidung die auch der
zehnkampf weltmeister lobt ich finds am
ende jetzt sehr gut weil wir eben
momentane situation haben in der ich mir
nicht vorstellen kann dass olympische
spiele so stattfinden wie sie sich die
sportler die daran teilnehmen irgendwie
immer erträumt haben und aber auch die
zuschauer verdient hätten
hygienisch gewappnet aber doch etwas eng
geschart um das hier geparkter
olympische feuer einwohner aus fukushima
gerne hätte ich einen fackellauf gesehen
aber was will man machen die gesundheit
ist wichtiger
das feuer am glimmen zu halten über mehr
als ein ganzes jahr dürfte dennoch eine
schwierige aufgabe werden
und fußball gespielt wird in den bundes
liegen auch erst im mai frühestens das
hat das präsidium der deutschen
fußball-liga empfohlen und es gilt als
sicher dass die vereine dem nächste
woche zustimmen
die deutsche wirtschaft muss durch die
korona krise wohl mit mehr einbußen klar
kommen als während der finanzkrise 2009
das sagt der bundeswirtschaftsminister
heute nach einer video-konferenz mit
wirtschaftswissenschaftlern
er will mit massiven hilfen aber auch
auf einen neuen aufschwung hinarbeiten
dass es die eine seite die andere ist
die frage wie unkompliziert und vor
allem wie schnell diese hilfen bei denen
ankommen die sie jetzt dringend brauchen
klaus brodbeck 17 mitarbeiter bis vor
kurzem noch 100 prozent auslastung und
jetzt 0 messebauer wie ihn hat die krise
besonders früh getroffen und auch
besonders hart
wir haben monatliche fixkosten von circa
60.000 euro wir haben keine einnahmen
wir haben in den letzten jahren re die
renditen von 0 bis 3 prozent erreicht
wir wissen nicht wie lange wir es
durchhalten
wir wissen aber auch nicht aufgrund der
rendite wie wir einen kredit in welchem
zeitraum wir den zurückzahlen können
wenig bleibt wie es war
der wirtschaftsminister berät mit dem
sachverständigenrat nur noch per video
über die auswirkungen von kurzarbeit
produktionsausfällen und krankenständen
das alles wird dazu führen dass die
wirtschaftlichen einbußen wahrscheinlich
höher sein werden als in der letzten
wirtschaftskrise in der banken- und
börsenkrise ich sage wahrscheinlich weil
es niemand so genau wissen kann noch ist
vielen unklar wie sie herr zugesagte
hilfen kommen und wann wir wissen
natürlich gar nicht wie schnell das
jetzt passieren kann wie das auch
funktionieren soll wo es kein
publikumsverkehr gibt also offenbar per
telefon und elektronisch das wird noch
eine ganz große aufgabe des tatsächlich
wirkt auch auszuzahlen diese sofort
helfen bevor die unternehmen pleite sind
seine und andere firmen unterstützen
sich jetzt gegenseitig damit ein paar
durchkommen irgendwie also noch viele
fragen offen aber sarah tacke es bei uns
aus unserer zdf rechts redaktion
sarah guten amt also wir sehen auf der
einen seite 1 milliarden hilfsprogramm
übrigens auch viele länder legen ihr
eigenes hilfsprogramm auf der anderen
seite unternehmen selbständige die
dringend hilfe brauchen
jetzt müssen wir darüber reden wie das
beides zusammenkommt was da dein tipp
wäre beginnen wir vielleicht mal bei
kleinstunternehmen und den selbständigen
schöne hier ist dass die milliarden die
der bund verteilen will wirklich
geschenktes geld ist und daran bekommt
jeder betroffene solo selbstständige
oder kleinstunternehmer indem er sich an
das jeweilige landesförderinstitut
wendet das in seinem bundesland
zuständig ist es zum beispiel in bayern
die förderbank bayern oder in thüringen
nennt sich das aufbaubank thüringen er
findet man alle informationen auf der
jeweiligen webseite anträge stellen und
dann sollen viele tausend euro fließen
als unterstützung und geschenk geben
ok und dann gibt es aber kredite die
zurückgezahlt werden müssen für
große unternehmen wie läuft es da genau
für mittelständler und große bekommen
aktuell in dieser krise kein geld
geschenkt aber sehr viel leichter
geliehen dafür müssen sich einfach an
ihre bank wenden und die leid aber
gerade geld mit großer leichtigkeit denn
es ist neu dass die bank für die kredite
für das geliehene geld nur mit 10 20
prozent haftet falls der unternehmer am
ende ausfällt für den rest haftet die
kfw also die förderbank des bundes das
heißt für große und mittlere kein
geschenktes geld aber ein mit
leichtigkeit geliehenes geld und das hat
sich zu den banken auch schon
rumgesprochen davon gehe ich aus ganz
herzlichen dank für die informationen
heute abend das virus auf seinem weg
durch europa dramatisch ist die lage
neben italien auch in spanien innerhalb
von 24 stunden gab es dort 600 neue
registrierte todesfälle
insgesamt starben rund 2800 patienten
nach einer corona infektion madrid hat
diese eislaufhalle deshalb zu einem
leichenhaus umfunktioniert frankreich
hat sein ausgehverbot weiter verschärft
joggen oder spazieren ist nur noch im
umkreis von einem kilometer rund um die
wohnung erlaubt und das maximal für eine
stunde gleiche bilder in london die
metropole fast menschenleer
nach langem zögern hat auch die
britische regierung ausgangs
beschränkungen erlassen und die zahlen
bei uns hier in deutschland auch da
gehen sie weiter nach oben
es gibt bis jetzt 31 1991 bestätigte
infektionen in deutschland die zahl der
toten ist auf 149 gestiegen das ist der
stand heute vor einer halben stunde
einen test auf das corona virus bekommen
in deutschland längst nicht alle vor
allem wenn sie nur leichte symptome
haben jeder mit husten oder schnupfen
kann sich aber einfach am telefon bei
seinem arzt melden und allein so künftig
bis zu 14 tage lang krank schreiben
lassen
bislang ging das nur bis maximal eine
woche ja alle zu hause der krone alltag
in deutschland die meisten familien
versuchen sich zu arrangieren entdecken
vielleicht auch neue möglichkeiten
aber natürlich gibt es auch probleme
möglicherweise
der große die familienministerin warnt
heute es könnte zu mehr gewalt kommt vor
allem zu misshandlungen von frauen und
kindern und praktisch niemand bekommt es
mit britta spiekermann im normalen
zeiten spielen hier kinder sie bekommen
eine warme mahlzeit aufmerksamkeit und
zuwendung in coruna zeiten ist die arche
anlaufstelle für arme kinder verweist
alle 25 standorte in deutschland sind
inzwischen geschlossen
es fehlt die zuflucht wenn das zuhause
kein sicherer ort ist sozialer isolation
das heißt viele menschen sind zu hause
in der kleinen wohnung fünf sechs sieben
personen in der 70 quadratmeter wohnung
da kann es natürlich ganz schnell zu
problemen führen wenn nur eine
kleinigkeit passiert eine situation und
extremer spannung eltern bangen um ihre
jobs kitas schulen soziale einrichtungen
sind geschlossen familien auf sich
gestellt potenzial für aggressionen für
gewalt hinter verschlossenen türen schon
jetzt gibt es einen trend hier sehen und
das sind die rückmeldungen die wir
bekommen aus den frauenhäusern dass
damit gerechnet wird dass es einen
zusätzlichen bedarf gibt eine
unterstützung im falle von häuslicher
gewalt viele frauen und kinder leiden in
deutschland unter häuslicher gewalt
schon lange arbeiten frauenhäuser an der
kapazitätsgrenze
jetzt könnte alles noch viel schlimmer
werden im corona ausnahmezustand ich
denke auch noch länger dauern
und dann müssen wir von ausgehen dass
das konfliktpotenzial natürlich mehr
wird und dass es daneben auch zu richtig
massiven konflikten kommt viele
frauenhäuser fordern von bund und
ländern finanzielle hilfen nicht nur um
mehr frauen und kinder schützen zu
können sondern auch für den fall dass es
zu personalengpässen kommt durch corona
ein weiteres zu nehmendes problem ist
der mangel an medizinischer ausrüstung
für den schutz der kranken und der
gesunden besonders atemmasken fehlen
weil sie immer wieder gestohlen werden
besonders aber weil der bedarf so groß
ist dass die hersteller nicht
hinterherkommen not macht erfinderisch
einige firmen haben jetzt ihre
produktion umgestellt wenn glas
berichtet
sie nehmen jetzt mundschutzmasken bei
der firma mai in albstadt in baden
württemberg wo normalerweise des zoos
boxershorts oder badehosen produziert
werden das eigentliche geschäft
eingebrochen
die masken nachfrage von krankenhäusern
ärzten und pflegeeinrichtungen dagegen
enorm zwischenzeitlich werden wir
natürlich überflutet von anfragen die
wir jetzt schon gar nicht mehr erfüllen
können glauben ein gestern hätten wir 3
millionen masken an den mann bringen
können
es sind mundschutzmasken vor allem für
pflegepersonal besser abschirmen der
atemschutzmasken stellen nun etwa vw bmw
und daimler aus ihren beständen den
behörden zur verfügung
gut möglich dass die autobauer arbeitet
auch an anderer stelle helfen können
mit 3d druckern die stadt autoteilen
vielleicht auch teile für
beatmungsgeräte herstellen könnten baden
württembergs ministerpräsident
kretschmann etwa bietet per brief
explizit um hilfe bei der produktion
medizinischer geräte
ich möchte mich mit der drängenden frage
und bitte an sie wenden
ob es der automobilwirtschaft sowie den
anlagen und maschinen bauern im land
möglich ist einen wichtigen beitrag zur
produktion solcher geräte zu leisten
einen beitrag leisten können sie im
moment auch beim oldigs stadt ihre
atemschutzmasken wie sonst an die
industrie zu liefern versorgen sie nun
medizin und pflegeeinrichtungen haben so
viel zu tun wie selten
unsere arbeit würde es natürlich
erleichtern wenn wir größere mengen an
zentralen stellen liefern könnten und
das ist ja gerade alles auch im
entstehen und es weit bekommen die
behörden im moment hilfsangebote von
unterschiedlichsten unternehmen die alle
versuchen zu helfen
es lohnt sich gerade in diesen zeiten
die so ineinander zu fließen scheinen
mal einen moment zurück zu schauen wie
alles begann vor gut drei monaten gab es
die ersten berichte über ein neues
corona virus in der chinesischen stadt
wo hahn in der provinz hubei seit ende
januar gilt dann für fast alle der knapp
60 millionen einwohner der provinz eine
ausgangssperre
mittlerweile aber sollen mehr als 90
prozent der erkrankten wieder gesund
sein
china lockert die auflagen und die
staatsmedien feiern das als den anfang
vom ende der krise
ab mitternacht dürfen gesunde die
provinz wieder verlassen
nur die stadt wo hahn selbst bleibt noch
geschlossen und beginnen live zu unserem
korrespondenten ulf röller in peking und
guten abend wie zeigt sich das denn
jetzt in china ist das wirklich so ein
kollektives aufatmen dass man spüren
kann
also man sieht schon eine menge
berichtet dass das leben zurück in die
städte kommt auch hier in peking das ja
eigentlich eine geisterstadt war für
wochen 22 millionen menschen
und man hat niemandem auf den straßen
gesehen jetzt zieht man die menschen
zurück in den straßen man sieht dass die
parks sich wieder füllen und man sieht
was natürlich die p gegner sehr gerne
machen sie gehen wieder essen die
restaurants sind wieder auf natürlich
alles so ein bisschen mit angezogener
handbremse als im restaurant kriegt man
gesagt wie man zu sitzen hat wie man
abstand halten soll
aber wie gesagt das geisterhafte ist aus
den städten ein wenig raus und dieses
land atmet ein bisschen auf und war aber
dann natürlich die frage wie sehr kann
man diesen zahlen jetzt trauern gibt es
jenseits der propaganda auch
verlässliche indizien
also ich glaube schon dass die zahlen
runter gehen ob sie wirklich so gut sind
wie die chinesische partei das macht da
kann man fragezeichen dahinter setzen es
wird wohl nicht ganz so intensiv
getestet damit eben diese zahl niedrig
bleiben aber ich glaube sie sind schon
gut man sieht eben auch dass die
wirtschaft unbedingt jetzt wieder
angekurbelt werden will das will die
chinesische regierung erreichen weil das
virus eben doch sehr zerstörerisch für
die chinesische volkswirtschaft war und
damit viele millionen von existenzen
gefährdet die kunst wird jetzt sein für
die machthaber dass sie es eben
hinbekommen die wirtschaft anzukurbeln
die millionen menschen von durch das
land reisen zu lassen aber dafür sorgen
dass eben nicht das virus mitreißt das
eben nicht durch die öffnung des landes
wieder neue infektionen entstehen
das wird die leistung sein die die
schöne ich partei bringen muss live aus
peking holt herzlichen dank das virus
hat den gesamten planeten im griff auch
in südamerika steigt die zahl der
bestätigten corona fälle rasant an und
besonders betroffen ist brasil
wie viele menschen dort haben angst
anders sieht das der brasilianische
präsident ja ihre ball szenario er nennt
das corona virus eine kleine grippe und
maßnahmen dagegen sind für ihn hysterie
jetzt kommt kritik am präsidenten sogar
von seinen anhängern christophe hocke
rat es ist wieder so ein moment der
viele brasilianer rätseln lässt ob ihr
präsident der lage gewachsen ist
am ende einer ernsten pressekonferenz zu
corona sagt boldt szenario spontan eine
kleine gruppe werde ihn nicht zu fall
bringen
brasilien fragt sich hat er den
tödlichen ernst der pandemie nicht
verstanden sorgt er sich nur um sein amt
oder um seine gesundheit wiederholt
szenario das virus herunter gespielt
jetzt antworten die menschen jeden abend
topfschlagen aus protest selbst in den
vierteln von rio und sao paulo wo die
meisten ihn gewählt haben vor raus rufen
sie wesentlich konsequenter als der
präsident handeln die gouverneure der
bundesstaaten unmissverständlich macht
die polizei in rio allen klar dass der
strand ab sofort gesperrt ist auch
einkaufszentren und
touristenattraktionen sind geschlossen
das gab es noch nie und am stadtrand
bauen sie in den messehallen ein
ausweich krankenhaus mit zunächst 500
betten im besten fall wird hier drinnen
nicht viel los sein aber wir müssen uns
vorbereiten denn unsere krankenhäuser
sind jetzt schon voll ausgelastet eine
hiobsbotschaft erreicht die behörden am
wochenende erstmals wird das corona
virus in rios überfüllten favelas
bestätigt es war nur eine frage der zeit
bis das virus die armenviertel erreicht
und doch ist es eine zäsur denn in den
favelas sind die menschen der krankheit
so gut wie schutzlos ausgeliefert
es mangelt auch so schon an fast allem
sauberem wasser
desinfektionsmittel gesundheitlicher
grundversorgung millionen menschen sind
jetzt unmittelbar bedroht fast überall
auf der welt also die sorge vor der
ausbreitung des virus und dann gibt es
tatsächlich betrüger die genau das
ausnutzen vor allem im internet shops
die desinfektionsmittel anbieten aber
nicht liefern
vermeintlich hilfreiche apps die nur
daten
und passwörter abgreifen wollen sven
ricken hat im netz mal sehr genau
hingeschaut schutzkleidung masken
angebliche wunder medikamente dirk
kuchel bekommt jeden tag mails voll mit
heilsversprechen die meisten sind der
versuch nutzer in eine falle zu locken
der angebliche anbieter safe maß zum
beispiel wirbt mit dem richtigen schutz
vor ansteckung dahinter steckt ein fake
shop ich würde ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
reingucken weil es handelt sich in den
meisten fällen ja um spam und das heißt
also von um nachrichten die sie gar
nicht verlangt haben von shops die sie
vielleicht gar nicht kennen und dann
sollte man grundsätzlich vorsichtig seit
fake shops wie diese gibt es viele
die medical smiles gmbh wird mit einem
großen angebot an gesichtsmasken zahlung
per vorkasse geliefert wird nie im
impressum ist der unternehmenssitz in
halstenbek bei hamburg angegeben
besonders dreist an dieser adresse gibt
es eine zahnklinik die deswegen schon
häufig anrufe bekam ich glaube einfach
dass viele auf diesen zug der angst
aufspringen dh die fälscher sozusagen
noch einmal zum leben erweckt werden
dann kauft man ja im internet und
überweist schnell kaufte zu überhöhten
preisen und kaufte sie vielleicht auch
bei shops sie gar nicht existieren auch
in diesem fall sind die betrüger
erfinderisch die johns hopkins
universität hält eine aktuelle pandemie
karte bereit betrüger fälschen das
aussehen ihrer seite und haben beim
ersten klick leichtes spiel wenn ich's
anklicke würde ich bei einem schlecht
gesicherten system ein trojaner auf
meinem computer installieren und das
würde dann den kriminellen ermöglichen
beispielsweise bankdaten auszuspielen
kreditkarteninformationen deutschlands
sicherheitsfirmen haben reagiert sie
bieten schutz software gegen hacker
derzeit kostenlos an sicherheit zum
nulltarif zumindest für das kommende
halbe jahr
soviel zum thema zunächst bei uns mehr
gleich in einem zdf spezial das läuft
direkt nach uns tests und therapien
der kampf gegen das corona virus und
dann um 20.30 die dokumentation
stresstest corona wie die krise
deutschland verändert und natürlich
bleiben sie online immer auf dem
laufenden
in unserem live-blog jederzeit auf heute
de und in der heute app und auch das ist
heute noch wichtig licht und schatten
gibt es in der kriminalstatistik für
2009 10 die innenminister horst seehofer
vorgestellt hat zunächst eine zahl die
auf stecken lässt es geht um bilder und
videos die missbrauch von kindern zeigen
wir haben die fälle im jahresvergleich
um 65 prozent zugenommen
insgesamt gab es jedoch weniger
straftaten ein minus von 2,3 prozent
besonders erfreulich die zahl der
wohnungseinbrüche sank auf 87.000 145
das ist der niedrigste stand seit 32
jahren haftstrafen heute in dresden für
acht rechtsextremisten der gruppe
revolution chemnitz und zwar zwischen
gut 2 und 5 1 halbjahren für das
oberlandesgericht dresden steht fest die
männer im alter zwischen 22 und 32
jahren gehörten einer terroristischen
vereinigung an sie wollten sich waffen
beschaffen und planten einen umsturz in
deutschland die gruppe hatte sich im
september 2018 gegründet als es in
chemnitz zu ausländerfeindlichen
demonstrationen und ausschreitungen kam
so und dann müssen wir heute abschied
nehmen von einem der generationen zum
lachen gebracht hat und zum nachdenken
auch der zweite vater von asterix ist
tot albers so hat mit stift papier und
seinem partner rené goscinny einen comic
kult erschaffen das gallische dorf der
zaubertrank der nicht endende hunger
nach wildschweinen und die erkenntnis
die spinnen die römer albert auch so
wurde 92 jahre alt der nachruf von
christel haus diese beiden sind der
schrecken aller römer ein kleiner
schlauer gallia und sein dicker sehr
gefühlvoller freund entsprungen sind sie
von 69 jahren seinem zeichenstift
alberta so die idee kam ihm und seinem
partner rené goscinny als sie über einen
neuen comic nachdachten der typisch
französisch sein sollte geboren waren
asterix und das rebellische gallische
dorf
wir haben überhaupt nicht mit diesem
erfolg gerechnet doch dann war auch in
deutschland die begeisterung fast
genauso groß wie in frankreich und den
anderen ländern auch das hat uns
beruhigt
so wollte eigentlich rennfahrer werden
doch dann entdeckte seine lehrerin ein
ganz anderes talent malen seine
schulhefte zeugen davon
so wurde comic zeichner mit asterix
gelang ihm ein meisterwerk dazu die
lustigen dialoge von partner goscinny
und die immerwährenden keilereien mit
den römern die ja bekanntlich sowieso
spinnen als goscinny 1977 stirbt
beschließt wieder so asterix weiterleben
zu lassen
ab jetzt schreibt er auch die texte vor
rund sechs jahren dann übergibt er das
zepter ganz animieren
das einzige was die gaia fürchten ist
dass der himmel ihnen auf den kopf fällt
ist er noch nicht und so können sich
diese beiden weiter der gepflegte
konversation widmen
das ist nicht zu übersehen
der himmel wird uns nicht auf den kopf
fallen wenig neues vom wetter zum glück
das bleibt zwar kühl aber sehr sonnig
mehr gleich von katja oliver damit
verabschiedet sich das gesamte team der
heute 19 das weiter verstreut denn je
ihnen diesen aktuellen nachrichten stand
gebracht hat ich empfehle den kollegen
claus kleber um 21.50 im heute journal
und morgen ist petra gerster an dieser
stelle für sie da wo immer es geht
machen sie sich einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
meine damen und herren während es über
nord und über südeuropa dichtere wolken
gibt strahlt die sonne von moskau bis
zur biskaya und wenn es tagsüber schon
so viel sonne gibt dann ist es nachts
meist klar und so sinken die
temperaturen bei uns auf null grad auf
norderney und bis -10 grad im vogtland
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 3 grad am alpenrand und maximal
12 grad hier am niederrhein und dazu
strahlt wieder die sonne bei böigem
ostwind das ist zum teil auch ein
südostwind wolken sind absolute
mangelware und das wird sich in den
nächsten tagen wenig ändern
es wird allerdings von tag zu tag etwas
wärmer am samstag erwarten uns bis zu 18
grad schön ab noch